why do distributors no longer do
marketing
because they don't care about the movies
there's no passion for the movies
it's just about
numbers
they look at a movie they say can we
make money off of it and if they can
then
they're not emotionally attached you
know when a filmmaker makes a movie i
mean i i don't want to
be
this is a crazy analogy but it's it's
like having a child
i mean it's a big deal making a movie is
a major major deal in someone's life i
mean the amount of time effort money
that you put into it this sweat
that you put into it i mean it's a big
big deal and you are so emotionally
attached to it and it's such a major
part of who you are in your life because
it's such a gigantic commitment and a
huge accomplishment
distributors don't share any of that
they don't have any of that passion they
don't understand any of that pain as a
matter of fact i have lots of
distributor friends obviously i come
from that world
and um you know we're constantly talking
at dinner you know i say you guys you
don't even understand
it's what's there to understand jeff
you don't understand how emotionally
attached people are and how important it
is and and when you just fluff it off
and and you know how hurtful it is
well it's business jeff and i say i know
it's business i know it's business but
i've been on both sides of this business
and i understand what filmmakers go
through and and what they you know are
dealing with
so i'm not asking you to be you know bad
business people or anything like that
but
they're not emotionally involved and
they're not even financially involved
these days anymore
so they have no stake in it
like when i say financially involved you
know getting a minimum guarantee
at least gets them connected and gives
them a little bit of risk but it's hard
to get that now you know it's especially
a significant one that where makes them
sweat a little bit
see very rare you get that so when
there's no financial attachment or no
emotional attachment why should they
have to get behind it and put too much
effort into it
basically it's a volume game for them
now because
a lot of their business is on avod
platforms where it's basically throw it
all up there and see whatever watch
people watch and just take a piece of it
and if you know if you have a hundred of
them going at the same time then
hopefully the volume will be enough that
you can make some real money but
individually each person's not going to
make very much but they don't care
because their business is volume and
their business is
i hate to say this because it's going to
disturb a lot of filmmakers who are
watching this but i'm going to wager to
guess that most
distributors don't even watch the movies
that they distribute they might watch 10
minutes of it maybe they flip through
and watch the first 10 the middle 10 the
last 10 just to make sure it's in focus
and working
can you imagine that somebody selling
your movie who hasn't even watched it
you know i mean how disappointing that
would be and they're supposed to talk
about it and be passionate about it
they've never seen it so that's why
they don't do marketing because they
don't really care and that's why a
filmmaker has to do it because they do
care and they're going to do it with
more passion now maybe not as much skill
because they don't do that for a living
and that's why it would be helpful to
deal with people who do do it for a
living and yeah will any marketer feel
as passionate about the film as the
filmmaker no of course not nobody's
going to feel more passionate about
their children than the parents
right
but there are people who will feel more
passionate than the you know like
teachers would feel more passionate
about
kids than you know than
or coaches or something like that people
are connected
the way a filmmaker you know like but a
distributor they just don't care
that's the main reason
you know how they say a good artist
should have a manager and an agent but
also be looking to book their own work
don't rely
just you'll be waiting by the phone or
your email so is it similar that if you
get a distribution deal if you're lucky
enough to have gotten that that then you
are finding who your audience is you're
going out there and you're
actually dealing with them you're not
relying on well my distributor just
won't they don't care it's just business
to them once in a while you'll get lucky
and a distributor will get behind it and
really try hard and because they realize
that there's potential and if they put a
lot of resources behind it they'll
generate more revenue and be more
successful with it once in a while
but i would not take that for granted so
as you say don't rely on it if it
happens feel like you're lucky in it you
know and you won the lottery don't rely
on it
figure that even when you get
distribution you're going to have to
support the distribution efforts with
your
marketing and awareness creation as much
as you can
and maybe you can't you know maybe you
can't and that's why a lot of filmmakers
get disappointed with distribution deals
because they say hey i gave it to a
distributor and they did nothing with it
they stuck it on a couple of platforms i
could have done that myself they
basically did nothing
um you know they
and
they didn't you know so
i say to them what did you do well it's
not my job to do it it's the
distributors i said well that's the new
norm the new narrative that i'm talking
about it actually is your job now
and i've heard that from a lot of actors
filmmakers
writers that's why i have a manager but
then they don't want to do other things
that could actually help propel them you
know
in the new narrative that i'm talking
about the the manager agent thing and if
you want to talk on the talent side
is basically the manager needs to
navigate the business elements so that
the person doesn't have to deal learn to
become you know their own lawyer and
business person the agent just needs to
keep an eye on you know what the
opportunities are right but
in the distribution world i mean
what is a producer writer director
who's making an indie film what's what's
the manager going to do they're going to
negotiate a distribution contract for
them i mean there's so many people who
can do that and i'm not sure they're
going to do it well anyways
and you know
agents like first of all
you know i i think that most indie film
people aren't going to get that anyways
for two reasons one is they can't afford
it like an agent manager they want to
make money they want retainers you know
yeah sure they're going to take a
percentage but they at least want a
retainer so who can actually afford to
have those people on staff you know and
working for you and secondly you know
agent managers need to also you know
make a living so hence they want to deal
with potentially bigger stuff
and indie films generally aren't big
enough the odd one is you know that will
make enough money to pay a five percent
commission to an agent or whatever it is
but for the most part
they aren't that's why it's so hard for
indie filmmakers especially writers
to get representation
because the agents don't want to spend
too much time on it because they don't
feel there'll be a return on their time
can you make a commercially viable movie
for 250 000
so it's interesting that number gets
thrown around a lot these days a quarter
of a million um i used to throw around
the number 750 like that was the number
that you needed to spend to make a
decent movie and i always used to say
hey i'm a decent filmmaker but remember
i didn't go to film school you know i
went to law school and business school
so i have the business side down pat um
i didn't go to film school so maybe i
don't have the artistic side down pat as
much you know but but when it comes to
spending money i kind of know how that
all works and i used to say as a
filmmaker i think you got to spend at
least 750 to make a decent movie just
because you got to give yourself enough
time to do it properly and
assuming you want to pay people you know
i don't ever i don't have the
connections to have people work for free
and i don't really want to ask them to
work for free so i'm not overpaying or
you know i'm not paying nobody's going
to get rich but you know i'm paying a
fair salary that type of thing so just
based on my experience i always felt 750
sort of was the minimum and
you know
somewhere between 750 and a million and
a half was a decent amount to get a
decent movie like good quality good
production value you know costumes
wardrobe you know and make the resources
you need to deliver a good movie
but
a lot of stuff has changed in technology
right so obviously cameras are cheaper
and and you don't need as much gear
sometimes as much staff you know crew
um
sometimes you get locations are
available i mean talent has not gone
down in price if anything has gone up
so a lot of filmmakers say to me yeah i
can make a really good movie for for 250
and i say okay i'm not going to argue
with that
but
don't think just because you put your
heart and soul into it and you tried
your best
that it makes it into a good movie
the ultimate test is let's watch the
movie and see if it's good don't say hey
i only had 250 to spend and that's the
best you can do for 250. that's not
gonna fly in the real world nobody's
gonna care they're gonna say okay nice
try but we don't want to spend our time
and money watching your movie it's not
like oh wow let's watch the best movie
that was made for 250. it doesn't work
that way so if you can really look it
lots of people have done it lots of
people have made movies for less than
100 grand we know that there's these
stories and myths and legends out there
of all these great films that were made
for you know very low budgets
i just don't i think those are anomalies
i think they happen far and few between
um but if you're a great filmmaker and
you got a good
crew and the chemistry's right and the
story's right and the acting and
everything happens
then what the heck i don't you know as i
say to all my clients
the customers out there i.e the viewers
nobody's going to ask you how much you
spent on your movie all they're going to
ask you they're just going to look at
your movie and say is it good or bad
they don't care how much you spend and
by the way when people talk about how
much they spend they lie anyways
everybody always says they spend 10
times more than they did and you know
some of it's real because remember
they're not getting paid so you know
people say oh i made a film for fifty
thousand dollars and then i say great
how many hours did you put oh i put uh
2 000 hours of my time in did you
include that no how much would you make
an hour hundred dollars so that's twenty
thousand dollars of time that you didn't
include
in your you know in your scenario so
your film wasn't fifty thousand was
seventy thousand because if somebody was
going to make the same film
they'd have to make it for seventy
thousand if i did my math rate it wasn't
i didn't mean 200 000 i meant 20 000 you
know time of their time
so people don't factor that in so the
numbers are always skewed anyways about
how much somebody spent on a movie but
at the end of the day it doesn't matter
it doesn't matter how much somebody
spent the only thing that matters is
that the movie's good
so i applaud anybody who can make a
great movie for a little amount of money
and by the way the people who say to me
i can make a movie for 250 i say maybe
you should be making some of my movies
because i'd be making a lot more money
if we were delivering my movies for 250
if you could deliver them oh well you
should give me a chance jeff and i said
i i
i don't trust that it can happen and
maybe i'm skewed maybe i think you need
you know
these resources and everything like that
so i i do believe that there are people
out there who making really good stuff
for 250 and maybe cheaper um
but don't think because you spent 250
that the contest is not
who made the best movie for 250. the
contest is did you make a great movie
and it doesn't matter what you made it
for because if you didn't make a great
movie i don't care if you spent two two
and a half million if you didn't make a
great movie you're not in the game
your movie's not selling the movie's got
to be good and i know we didn't talk
about that before when i talk about
distribution but remember i said i'm
going to check that box that you made a
great movie you got to make a good movie
fair is fair right if you want somebody
to pay and spend their time watching
your movie and pay to watch it
give them some value give them some
entertainment value give them a good
movie
does having a higher budget let's say
over 500 000 guarantee that your movie
is probably going to be of a higher
caliber story wise
if you're a good producer
slash director like a good producer
director team who knows how to
deploy their resources you know very
very effectively
then
i would say the more you have to spend
the better quality your movie is likely
going to be
as long as you're not wasting it like if
you're putting it on screen you know
like if you let's say i'll give you an
example okay let's say you have a 500
000 movie right
and then you get an extra 50 000
if you go and hire like a fancy caterer
who's going to do the meals yeah will
your crew and cast feel a little bit
better
sure they will but will it make your
movie better probably not but if you
spend that fifty thousand dollars
potentially on one scene where it's a
big production you know a bigger
location with more extras or something
like that then it'll make your movie
better so that's what i mean by
deploying the resources effectively
so if you're
you always have to be careful with your
resources no matter what you have so
people think at 250 i have to be more
careful than at 500 no you have to be
careful of both levels and at 750 just
deploy them as best you can so that you
put most of it on screen so that your
movie looks better so obviously the more
you have to spend if you're deploying it
wisely you have a better chance at
making a
higher quality looking movie you know
potentially more production value now
obviously it's going to always end up
there's there's elements that doesn't
matter how much you spend
acting
all right now you could say the more i
spend on actors the better actors i'm
going to get i don't personally believe
that i believe that there's good actors
at every
price range
and hopefully get good performances out
of them all right so you could say you
know i'll get a better cinematographer
if i spend more money you'll definitely
get a more experienced cinematographer
because you know they have that's why
they're charging more because they've
done more and you know chances are it's
more predictable but it doesn't mean a
brand new cinematographer can't you know
shoot a great movie i mean there's young
upcoming people who are really talented
who just need a break so hopefully you
get one of those you know and directors
and all this kind of stuff um hopefully
it all gels and and
so i that's where you the magic can
happen at low budgets where everything
gels and you just get great performances
great directing
sometimes you know experience does
matter and you don't make the rookie
errors because you've done it before
and that's why spending more money on
people who know what they're doing is a
little bit more predictable
but it doesn't mean that people who
haven't done it before can't do it well
but you know to get back to your
question yeah if you had an extra 250
and you put most of it on screen
your movie's going to look better it's
just going to look bigger and and you
know hopefully like when i say on screen
you're using more extras your costumes
are better your production value is
better by the way if if the story is bad
the acting's bad you could spend 5
million and still come up with a bad
movie i mean you know a bad movie is
going to be a bad movie
so
it does start with a decent story a
decent vision from the director and good
performances and then the rest is just
capturing it properly you know focus
sounds the shots you choose that kind of
stuff
earlier you said the audience doesn't
care what you paid for your movie i know
film festival audiences might care
though because they just want to know
what was your budget range and how can i
emulate what you did kind of everybody
lies i go to tons of festivals i sit in
these screenings and they say well how
much was your budget oh i'm going to
tell you the truth and then they they
usually triple it or quadruple it nobody
wants to say they made a 10 000 movie
because it feels too small right
so how do you know what's real unless
you've done the accounting for it
um i've been there done that i know what
things cost i know you know now when a
filmmaker says to me hey i didn't pay
anybody
then i say great um you know you're
lucky that you got people to work for
free
i don't do the movies that way i believe
they should get paid but i'm not saying
it's wrong you know sometimes people say
oh i spent five years making my movie
because i just shot on weekends or this
or that type of thing i say okay fine
but you know i'll gain it's not my
business model i'd rather shoot 20 days
consecutively get it done release it do
the next thing so everybody's got a sort
of a different business model and a
different vision of what that could be
but when i say people don't care about
how much they spent people like to
discuss it they like to throw numbers
around they like to because you know
they want a point of reference for
themselves to see you know can i make a
movie how much does it really cost so
there are people who are curious
especially at festivals you know who
want to sort of know because maybe
they're thinking of making their own
movies so they're doing that as a point
of reference
um but
if you've watched a movie
and you've left the theater and you said
wow that's a great movie and then
somebody said to you oh that cost fifty
thousand or five million
you'd be way more impressed if it was
fifty thousand wouldn't it be way more
because all of a sudden this great movie
this epic movie was made for fifty
thousand dollars the surprise
would be on the low end as opposed to
the high end so i always joke and i say
if i would ever win an academy award in
my speech i'm gonna say what the actual
budget was because it's gonna be so much
lower than what anybody expected it to
be you know because everybody expects if
it's a good movie that it has to cost
all
so much money and by the way
here's the other problem with the
narrative that that indie filmmaker
everybody throws around hollywood style
numbers oh i'm making like you know i
told you before i get phone calls i'm
making a five million dollar feature
and uh and it's all ready but i just
need you know finance and distribution
i say whoa
time out you're you're making a five
million dollar feature but it's not
finance and you don't have distribution
so how are you making the five million
dollar feature again like
in your mind you're making a five
million dollar feature but in reality
what you're probably going to spend is
fifty thousand dollars i mean that's
what's really going to happen if you
want this feature made unless you are
connected to some really high net worth
individuals who are prepared to make big
donations to you
so everybody still throws around the big
numbers especially in the hollywood
circles and everybody wants to pretend
holly and at festivals you know it's
hollywood talk right which is you know
2.5 i made my movie for you know 3.2 and
blah blah blah and it's like
all right whatever
doesn't look like you did so you know
it's different strokes for different
folks
what does it cost to get bankable stars
in your movie so bankable stars you mean
a-list talent basically people who can
who people say who's in it and when you
say the name they say oh i know that
person that's a bankable star all right
so that's what i call bankable because
there are sort of secondary bankable
words oh i've heard of that person as
opposed to oh
you know when someone goes to see a
movie in the theater the first question
they ask is who's in it and you know
that's why a-list actors make so much
money because people say oh if they're
in it i'll go see the movie right they
don't say what's the movie about they
generally say who's in it even for
animated films they'd say that's the
crazy part like i mean you're talking
voice a talent you know
so what does it cost um it's
flexible but a-list talent cost more
than
it than indie film producers can afford
and the other thing is that chances are
a-list talent doesn't want to do indie
films unless it's their story or they're
personally connected and they want to
direct and the reason is is because
an a-list
actor does not want to be associated
with a c-list film like the production
value is too low and it's going to taint
their reputation
i say unless it's their story and
they're or they're very connected to the
filmmaker or whatever and they want to
help share that vision
so i'm going to say that you know a-list
talent you know is in the
seven-figure range like you know the
million-dollar plus range um b
b or say a minus list or b plus you know
is going to be high six figures
um and you know when you're making a
movie for a half a million dollars or
even a million dollars
and you want an a-list actor then your
budget just doubled you're gonna have a
two million dollar movie now a lot of
people will say i mean all the
distributors are watching this will say
it's worth it
because that's what's going to sell the
movie
and they're right
it is worth it
if you know for sure you got a sale on
the movie see if you go that route and
you don't get your sale you've just
doubled your budget you've taken a huge
risk and maybe it's not going to work
but some people say it's a better risk
to put an a-list actor in and spend that
money it's less of a risk than it is to
not have that a lot of international
distributors will say to you don't even
bother making a movie unless you have
recognizable bankable talent
which i don't
totally disagree with
but you know the genre i work in family
i don't really use any recognizable
talent
because i think it's more about the
story than it is about the actor no it
recognizable talent wouldn't hurt but i
don't think the numbers would justify in
terms of the selling side the cost of
the actor
now there's some people that use
previous a-list actors who maybe now
have become
you know i don't know what their rating
would be but then there's a draw in that
too that someone that had been out of
the limelight for a while hadn't been
working for whatever the reason is and
now has made a comeback and they may be
totally different persona wise
appearance wise than they once were and
then that's probably a draw as well very
very big draw that's very very common
you know i call them a minus or b plus
list actors people who are not you know
in the limelight you know they're not
the top 50 or whatever in hollywood but
they're still they've done they've been
there done that and are very
recognizable very good for international
sales because people still recognize
their face or their name so that's
much more common and and it is bankable
also but it's not cheap
you know a b-list actor could be
50 000 a day
not uncommon to see that at all and
they're worth it you know first of all
they're good actors right so you pretty
well can depend on them giving a good
performance usually
um and yeah they have that that sale
ability or what you call the bank
ability um and
you don't know for sure how bankable it
is um but you're pretty certain it's
better to have them not than not to have
them but it's just it's just a finance
equation right so like if you were to
say to me why don't you put you know
like two b list actors in to lead roles
in your movie and i'm gonna say because
it'll double the you know be half a
million dollars in in that fee
and i don't think i'm gonna i think i'll
only
increase my sales by say 350 000. so i'm
doing some calculations beforehand and
saying it's not
feasible for me to do that but if i did
it the other way and said you know by
putting a 500 000 actor in i could get
you know a million dollars of extra
sales of course i would do it
what's the likelihood of someone who
just has an idea so no screenplay no
trailer no artwork no attachments
getting a pitch
inside netflix
minus one to zero
unless unless they have an agent who is
really likes them a lot and wants to get
them in there first of all netflix
doesn't take unsolicited pitches none of
the streamers take insulin none of the
studios or the streaming companies take
unsolicited pitches meaning you can't
phone them up
they don't have like a place a website
or an entry point where you can phone
them up and say i have a great idea i'd
like to pitch you it doesn't exist
i mean they publish that that's right on
their website okay
so the only way you can get in is with
either a agent
slash manager a lawyer so whoever
somebody who's connected internally in
there or a
distributor who's done business with
them all right that's the only way that
you can even attempt to get a pitch
um so
so right away you can't get indirectly
um so maybe you can get in that way but
highly highly highly unlikely also
because you haven't done anything before
i mean they have a lineup and i mean
let's talk netflix netflix has a lineup
at their store so long they have every
single major filmmaker in the world who
has done anything wants to do it for
netflix right because i mean they got a
gigantic audience right
so think of all the people ahead of you
in line and what their credentials are
relative to what your credentials are
so i would say if you want to attempt it
then
you try to get in line for an agent who
you're not going to get the time of day
from either
so then
keep working at your craft
sounds like don't don't don't just
expect to jump along here's the way to
yeah you're not going to jump the line
there's no way and i can't even think of
getting lucky to jump the line um the
the only way that you can sort of get
ahead a little bit is is do something
make something that is
notable that gets you that that that
their usher says hey who did that and
takes you closer to the you know to use
a metaphor type of thing right and that
would be
here's a crazy crazy um
counter-intuitive thing about netflix
that most people don't know
which makes no sense but it's true
and it's not just netflix by the way
it's pretty well all the streaming
companies okay it's pretty well all the
big releasing companies
the more
popular you have
the more success you've done in when
you've released your movie the more
attractive you are to netflix
so get this
you want to make a move you want it you
want to get their attention
make a movie
put it onto youtube for free
create as much awareness as possible
spend you know
effort tons of effort creating awareness
get two million views
then all of a sudden you're going to get
onto their radar screen and everybody
says wait wait a second i just gave my
movie away to two million people like
why would anybody want it now after that
and i'd say
they would say because they have 160
million people and 2 million is a test
market for them and they just need to
see that hey people 2 million people
like your movie then all of a sudden now
they're going to be interested that's
the best way to get their attention
now how do you get that i mean you know
getting you go viral you have a great
movie you create awareness that's what
this is all about but that's how you get
the attention of a major streamer now
it's as counterintuitive as that sounds
it's not really when you think about the
theatrical business right
the movies that netflix wants the most
and all the major streaming companies
are the big movies
and you know pre-covet the big movies
open theatrically to you know half a
billion dollars worth of business like
you know 500 000 or 50 million people
seeing these i don't know whatever the
numbers are didn't do the math properly
but 25 million people have already seen
the movie why would anybody want that
everybody's already seen it but yet
those are the ones that are most coveted
and have the get the biggest payoffs at
the streaming companies why because the
streaming companies believe that
people want to see them again these are
big movies and they'll want to be seen
twice
you know and then you know or three or
four times and that's why they're so
valuable even though they've already
been seen you don't use it's like love
you don't use it up there's endless
amounts so you know you don't yeah you
use up one view with a viewer but they
have ten more left or five more whatever
the case may be so that's why i'm saying
if you can release a movie an
independent movie and get tons and tons
of awareness
then you'll you'll get on the radar
screen a lot better you'll get to the
front of the line a lot quicker and
people will say okay i like this what
else you got
so on one hand plan for success
submit to some of these higher tier
festivals
don't don't just assume don't rest on
that you'll get in but at the same time
don't sabotage yourself where you think
that you just have this amazing idea and
somehow you can get in to netflix to
pitch it
with no other vetting yeah i don't
believe in miracles but if you believe
in miracles like that would be in the
miracle category like i have a great
idea i've never done anything before and
i think that i'm gonna get in the door
on netflix and they're gonna fall in
love with it so to me that that's a
miracle that's like so far beyond
reality
um
maybe it's happened you know i doubt it
maybe it could happen once and maybe
everybody the myths and legends will be
created around it but
i put that in the category of a miracle
how about we move the needle a little
bit of miracles and talk about a
finished screenplay first finished
screenplay am i getting into netflix
you're still in the you're still in the
category of miracles you're just maybe a
little further down
okay yeah no you're if you're not a
proven writer first of all they're not
reading it second they're not accepting
it they're not reading it unless it goes
in through a literary agent who they do
business with which you can potentially
do that but how do you get that literary
agent you got to get them so that's
almost as hard as getting into netflix
itself so you're still it's it's tough i
know it's not like this is one of those
things where you know you say speak the
truth and the truth kind of hurts a
little bit
yeah it's reality so you've got this
screenplay you put your heart and soul
into it it's probably really good
and you can't get anybody to read it
so that's why
sometimes you go down both paths you
spend a lot of time getting an agent or
trying to get an agent who hopefully can
get in the door and pitch it to somebody
but you don't put all your eggs in that
basket at the same time you start to
think about okay how do i do this myself
maybe
one happens before the other or you know
you never know
and we go back to the einstein quote
yeah so so you're not you're not banging
your head against a wall and you're
trying a different route which is more
of a proven route instead of my thing is
different because we all think our story
is special yeah and there's nothing
against anybody's story
or their writing or their skill but
you kind of have to go through certain
channels it can't just be yeah like
hollywood and when i say hollywood i'm
including you know like not just the
studios i'm including you know the big
streamers now and you know the basically
the people who control most of the
eyeballs
they've done a really good job of
locking out all the indies that's they
don't do it on purpose but the reason
they do it is because they they deal in
such high caliber product i mean it's a
business decision right like they're
dealing in very very high-end production
quality
content and actors and that type of
thing and they just don't need to waste
any time on indie film production it's
just it's it's a nuisance it's
aggravating like
that's it any game they have so many so
much time in a day why would they spend
it on that when they have the resources
to do so much more bigger caliber stuff
which is what they're doing like look at
this what the streamers offer now
i mean the value that they give to to
consumers ten dollars a month for like
multi-million dollar productions with
a-list actors and and fantastic
storylines and writing and everything
like that how do you beat that like
you're you know an indie film producer
like how do you even compete with that
so
looking at it from that perspective like
fear is fair right they got a business
to run they got viewers to satisfy so
and they have all the resources to do it
and and revenue coming in from
subscribers so why do they need to focus
on why does any exec at a streaming
company need to read an indie script
when they got 50 other scripts sitting
beside them written by in-house writers
who were you know high-caliber
successful you know people who are on
staff they don't
that's that's the reality because here's
the thing about indie filmmaking that
i'm going to give it credit for
it's generally a lot more creative than
than all than big budget film that the
big bunch of stuff is very well done and
i love it um but it's
predictable it's formulaic it's you know
a lot of sequels a lot of stuff like
that because they you know they know
what the audience wants they just keep
giving them the same thing over and over
so you know the innovative stuff is
going to come from the indie film world
and the big studios know that it's just
very aggravating to access it all so
once in a while there's a breakthrough
and you know and they have lots of
innovation internally as well
they encourage innovation you know from
their internal writers
but um you know the cutting edge stuff
is coming from the indie film world so
that's where the indie film world has a
little bit of not an advantage but you
know you know it's a unique approach
but it's just a matter of organizing it
to get it through so that it can get
through the system
can we go back in time to that first
netflix meeting you had what year was
this
2014
14 or 15. yeah 14 or 15. the first one
was 14 because i hadn't made the movie
yet i made the movie in 15 the first one
so i pitched them before i made the
movie
how did you get that meeting netflix was
a different company back then they
actually you know what i actually phoned
them up
and i emailed i got the name
you could get they published
email addresses like the company wasn't
gigantic
it was big obviously it was still very
big but
it wasn't what it is today and you could
actually get
the names of buyers and you could email
them and they would actually return an
email so that's what i did i emailed oh
i had to email probably 15 or 20 times
um made cut left a couple of voice
messages because you could also get that
and then finally i got a return phone
call and
you know i had done other movies before
so it wasn't my first had it been my
first i probably wouldn't have gotten
them the meeting
um that that was my fourth movie
um the one that i pitched them on so i'd
already made three before so i kind of
knew what i was doing i said you know i
here's what i've made here i'm an
experienced filmmaker blah blah blah
i've got this movie you got the olympus
coming up can i pitch you on it so they
heard the pitch but then they said um we
can't take a chance on you until we see
the movie so make the movie and then
come back
but they didn't guarantee anything they
just said make the movie and show it to
us when it's done
so the movie finished yeah how soon
before you're picking up the phone or
emailing after that
the movie wrapped at you know 505 on a
thursday and at 506 i was picking up the
phone
literally okay no no i mean i was i was
just saying okay i'm finished shooting
you know
i didn't show it to them obviously until
after it's finished edited and
everything like that but no no i was
anxious but
again
back then i was depending on it a little
bit more and i was much more hopeful
than i am today in terms of my realism
level
um
so
because i was a little more naive the
truth the truth is i just wasn't as
beaten up as i am now so
um i really really was hoping that they
would take it um but by the way the
movie before that
i made it for disney and i had i had got
into disney and i it was called king of
the camp it was a kids movie a camp
musical just like camp rock and it was
really it was great movie i loved making
it and it was so disney and i met with
the disney channel twice and we talked
about it and i came really really close
so i knew i had the flavor i had the
taste of what it was to be and
ultimately they said no
um and it broke my heart
but at least i got there at least i had
the pitch and you know i sat in the
disney office and and and they watched
the trailer and i saw you know i got to
that and they saw the movie and
ultimately and you know it was it was a
fair note i think it was terrible no to
get but as they say no is the second
best answer
um but so so i'd been there done that so
with netflix it was like okay i'm not
going to set myself up for
disappointment but i really really
really want this
and and i got lucky
and and it sounds like too there were
ways to get in touch with people that i
mean you said you were incredibly naive
but also there were there was more
access points way more access so there's
no more access like back then it wasn't
like they would not look at unsolicited
material they actually looked at
unsolicited material now it's done it's
finished
they get it's they're too big they have
too many yeah it's it's so that what
happened back then does not happen
anymore for obvious reasons
yeah it's so tiny and by the way they
weren't doing any original programming
back then i mean they just probably
started i forget what their first series
was that they made internally but it was
all
all acquisitions so they needed product
so there was a lot look at the year that
i sold them that movie
i can't remember statistically they told
me i can't remember the number exactly
but they it was something like they
bought 900 independent films that year
and the year i sold them the last movie
they bought 300. oh wow so
because they're making stuff internally
right so they don't need as much
external product as they do now they
still need some but generally it's
bigger stuff
so it's gotten harder and by the way
it's funny so i've got three movies on
netflix and i sold them three
i think i have less of a chance now even
having done business with them three
times of actually selling them something
more than i had back then
just because they're so big and they
have so much internal production that
it's gotten even more difficult since
you'd already worked in distribution
didn't you have a number of contacts you
could count on to try to get you in the
door
even after let's say some of the window
closed of
their email addresses being online for
you to access them yeah absolutely no a
lot of distribution is networking and
people who worked at one company often
end up in another company or switch
around and you know you keep
hopefully you have your friendships with
them and your business relationships and
and they i do get a lot of pitch
meetings that way because i know people
i mean that's a big component of
distribution as it is in any business
right is networking
so um yeah so i'm not as active in
distribution anymore so i don't have as
many contacts as all newer people and
younger people but the people who i have
known for many years who are still
active i still get meetings
how does one become active in
distribution let's suppose someone's
starting from the ground level and they
want to be able to build that rapport
with people what are some good ways they
can do it themselves so it's funny you
ask that because i i do teach at san
diego state university i teach
filmmaking and i said to a lot of my
students you know
that you might want to consider going
into distribution to start your career
not production
and know that you know in five or ten
years after you do distribution you'll
end up hopefully in production and just
you know make sure you guide yourself in
that direction
that's how you do it you got to work in
it like you can't expect to be a working
film producer and understand the
distribution circles because you're not
in them you got to work in a
distribution company go to the markets
meet your competitors meet other people
meet buyers
the distribution companies are
constantly meeting with buyers
their drink having drinks and dinner and
all this kind of stuff and meetings and
you get to know these people and you
know and you develop relationships over
time but you have to work in
distribution to develop those
relationships
or go to film markets so buy a pass
no no no no you can go to film markets
and kind of be on the periphery but
you're not going to get in the inner
circles uh i see yeah no if you really
want to get those relationships you got
it like listen a lot of people go to
film markets and festivals and sit in
panels and see the people and once in a
while somebody's nice enough to answer
some questions or meet afterwards or
whatever
but it's not the same you're not
developing that kind of relationship
because you're not doing business
together you're just kind of an irritant
that you're a filmmaker who wants their
attention that's that's the truth you
know um so they'll if they're polite
they'll give you the time of day
most of them are polite so they don't
bother because they don't you know it's
like being a celebrity everybody wants
your attention and you just don't have
time to give it to everybody and
everybody's going to pitch on the same
thing and just get tired of it after a
while like if you're a netflix buyer at
a market
you're a celebrity like you almost need
security to walk through the marketplace
because everybody is gonna like just
just
divulge you know just jump all over you
they just want your attention for a
second
right
just to clarify the first time you
pitched netflix were you pitching them
an idea or
an actual film
a good great question so
the film wasn't made so i guess it's an
idea but the film there was a script
there was the production was ready to go
all the actors were in place i knew
where i was shooting it was just like
pre-production i pitched them at that
phase so the movie i'd already financed
the movie by the way i didn't need them
to finance the movie the movie was
already financed ready to go ready to be
shot
but i felt like you know had i if i were
to do it again i would pitch them even
earlier this time but but i pitched them
at that point
and
by the way i didn't just pitch netflix
i pitched everybody this wasn't
exclusive netflix i mean netflix was one
of the companies i pitched i pitched
every studio
i mean disney was where i was hoping to
put that movie
full out i mean disney was the target
for it it was you know girl-centric it
was
female empowerment 12-year-olds i mean
it's the disney audience frankly i was
shocked that disney didn't buy it disney
bought it for the disney channel for the
rest of the world but not the united
states i was shocked i expected the sale
to come from them
so i'm not disappointed that it came
from netflix as a great customer and
ultimately worked out fantastic they had
a huge huge audience but it was the
disney audience that i was like when i
pitched my investors and they said where
are you like what's your niche audience
who's your niche target i said it's
disney i mean
we're setting up the movie it's a disney
s style movie it attacks their audience
this is who we're going for
so and i had several meetings with them
because i knew the people there
um and they just said no and then
luckily netflix said yes but you know i
also pitched pretty well every studio i
mean i had i knew a lot of people like
sony warner
um fox i knew people at all these places
through my distribution days so i was
able to get meetings
so that's how it happened
but it happened just before i made the
movie so there was lots to pitch on and
i had made a promo reel i obviously i
couldn't shoot make a trailer because i
hadn't shot anything yet but i cut a
promo reel almost like a little sort of
three minute documentary about
who the i'm making the movie about where
i'm shooting it little narration that
type of thing just to make it a little
bit more visually appealing and it was a
good promo reel did they say why
you wouldn't they didn't want to take on
u.s territory netflix i mean uh disney
i don't they didn't like the movie
they don't tell you why they don't tell
you why okay
and even if they do tell you why it's
just make you feel good you know it's
what are they going to say to me it's
not a good movie or it doesn't you know
what you know what they actually they
did say you know what they said they
said it doesn't um
suit our audience
and i said
okay
this is confusing to me number one is
disney channel rest of world
took the movie and it suits their
audience but disney channel usa said it
doesn't suit our audience and then i
said that to them and they said it's a
different audience
and i said you're kidding me
but who am i gonna say what am i gonna
argue i mean you know
i just take everything to mean we don't
like it you know thanks a lot nice try
no matter what they say i just that's
what i hear they could say anything and
i hear
sorry nice try come back tomorrow
yeah i just wasn't sure how much they
told you because that's very fascinating
that they the rest of the world liked it
but the u.s but i don't believe it you
don't believe it i don't believe i know
first of all i know darn well that that
movie plays to their audience they just
didn't have room for it or whatever
that's what they told me it was you know
whatever they needed to tell me to be
polite and you know and get me out the
door
that movie plays to their audience we
all know it they know it i know it you
know it's the world is not different
that way 12 year old girls are 12 year
old girls everywhere
how do you articulate distribution and
sales forecasts to investors
well articulate them i show them charts
and basically i show them what i believe
the revenue
generation is going to look like over
what period of time which is the cash
flow analysis and then i put it into a
nice concise chart so that they can see
it in sort of a one page that's how i
articulate it now how do i create it
i do my own sales forecast because i
have enough distribution experience to
sort of know what to expect what the
levels are what people are paying it
changes all the time obviously because
as the market develops and as new
customers come in or different
technology whatever so you have to
constantly keep revisiting that
but you generally do a revenue forecast
based on either
comparable movies that have
gone in the past not too far in the past
that you can compare to
based on your own experience based on
what you believe you're going to get
from a certain marketplace
and you do them at i do them at five
different levels like low
semi low medium medium high high so i do
five levels some people do 10 levels
some people do three levels you know you
can't do you could do one level but you
know it's
so i show what sort of the
average that we can expect is what you
know the home run is what the disaster
is
and um
but a lot of people pay for that so
there's companies that that you can buy
revenue forecasts from that do it for
you know as a service and you pay a lot
of money actually
i've seen lots of those forecasts
i
don't think they're so credible but you
need something you got to show something
to investors to say that you've done
your homework and this is what a
credible company that has compared it to
sort of like movies
has shown the reason i don't think
they're so credible is
several reasons one is they're using
movies that have played like 10 years
ago they can't they're talking home
video numbers home video doesn't even
exist anymore you know so they're
comparing
completely different technologies and
release patterns
two is they're usually using movies that
are bigger at budgets
than what an indie film would be so you
know like they're comparing my movie to
home alone
hello i mean they're not even in the
same league they're different businesses
you know so but you know it's family
audience and this and that type of thing
so i just
i'm
so so financially
um response like not respond i'm
responsible but but i'm i'm i'm so
critical financially i i gotta make sure
that it makes sense and sometimes
the the comps as they call the
comparables are not as credible as you
know when you talk to say a sales rep
who is in the market right now who deals
with today's audience and today's
platforms and you sit them down and say
what do you think
and it doesn't matter what 10 movies did
10 years ago what matters is what they
think because they're out there
interacting with customers all the time
and selling movies to them
now i also have relationships with some
agents and distributors around the world
so i'm able to call them up and say okay
what do you think and nobody gives
definitive answers they give well it
could be this it could be that it could
be at least you get a ballpark and it is
a ballpark but you say to your your
investors you know here's the ballpark
here's the range
you know
it could be a big range you know and
here's what you think the target's going
to be
and it's like no different than any
other business you know opening a
restaurant what do you think your
customer base is going to be and how
many meals you're going to sell
you know building a condominium complex
what's the revenue going to be it's just
like that maybe a little less
predictable than that because it's a
movie
do you talk to your students at ucsd
about that i mean do they want to know
how can i create this even if it's just
for play and excel yeah they do but it's
so i'd need a whole course on that
actually it's so extensive first of all
you have to understand finances a little
bit too and and i do get into i said i
mentioned cash flow you see so there's
how much revenue you're going to
generate but what the time frame it's
going to take to generate it and that
speaks to sort of return on investment
or internal rate of return so for
instance if you invested say a thousand
dollars in in today and next year i gave
you back two thousand dollars you would
have gotten you know 100 return on your
you know
or 200 roi like double your money right
but over a year
but if if i returned it to you two years
later it would have been over two years
so it's a sort of a different
financial analysis for an investor
because they're looking at their annual
rate of return so the longer it takes to
return the money the lower their return
on investment has been or their internal
rate of return as we call it this is
beyond what film students want to learn
i mean film students don't sign up to
learn this is accounting stuff i mean
this is stuff you learn in business
school
you know this finance right so i don't
get i talk about it but i don't get into
too much depth but ironically we just
finished that unit on distribution and
part of the assignment they have to do
an assignment part of the assignment is
doing a very very high level cursory
revenue forecast and everybody said how
would we know how to do that and i said
just guess
and they said what's the point i said
you'll understand the point in five
years from now just guess okay and the
point of that exercise if my students
watch this video is that
they have to go through the motions to
look at the different sort of revenue
streams
vod television international so so now
they're considering what revenue streams
there are and they're just putting
numbers in it doesn't matter what the
numbers are it's the format of what they
have to think about the numbers don't
matter today because they're going to
change tomorrow and in 10 years or five
years when they go to do their films
there'll be a whole different
marketplace with maybe some different
categories it's just the concept of
going through the motions to understand
how to set it up
that's what matters
and once they turned in those
assignments and you talked about it as a
group i'm assuming maybe you did maybe
you didn't what was their impression
of the revenue forecast right so they
had to create and even they're just
plugging in these numbers and they're
just maybe guessing the revenue forecast
is a tiny tiny component the major
component of the assignment was
marketing was how to create awareness it
was well it was basically
deciding who your audience so each
everybody picked a film to use some
people pick someone my film some people
they got to they had to choose a feature
film
this is what they do then they have to
tell me who their audience is and why
then they have to tell me how they're
going to create awareness with that
audience so which is a whole marketing
campaign like what they're going to do
with social media they're going to do
paid advertising how much they want to
spend and why they can justify that
spend
then they're going to tell me what
platforms how they're going to make it
accessible to the audience are they
going to do a theatrical release are
they going to do you know video on
demand are they going to try to do
subscription if so what do they expect
is their return so they have to do all
the research on all the platforms and
what to expect will they do television
afterwards
will they do date releases this kind of
stuff that's the core of it now how much
they're going to make is literally a
separate course they i do that i do two
things sort of as add-ons which are
worth fewer points everything is
point-based um sort of how much what the
revenue would be and and the other thing
is do a distribution agreement
so i give them a template for a full
distribution agreement so they can read
it and see it and then i give them a
distribution memo and again they say
well how would we know this and i say
you won't just make it up because i
don't care what they say as the like the
term of the deal i care that they know
here's the the items that go into a
distribution agreement you have to know
the territory the term the language you
know is it exclusive you know what the
payouts gonna be what it
i just care that they look at the
categories it doesn't matter what the
numbers are it's funny to read the
numbers because they're all over the
place but it doesn't matter it's the
thought process that goes into
understanding what goes into one of
these documents
have you ever pitched a completed film
to netflix
oh yeah yeah
definitely
well
the first one was completed i mean i
pitched it before but then i had to
pitch it after to get it sold the second
one was a completed film kiss and cry
that that was pitched after the fact
um i pitched
do you want me to go through that one
he's already is yeah i pitched another
one that they said no to which i think
is my best film ever but uh they didn't
think so and they said no and they
didn't tell you why
didn't
no wasn't a fit for the audience even if
they did honestly i i honestly don't
even hear why like because
i feel like it's just being polite
whatever it is like if you say it's not
a fit for your audience then
their audience is so big everything's a
fit for their audience they they own the
entire world audience so
i mean if they say it's not an
entertaining movie then
truthfully i guess my ego is too big to
believe that because i've done so many
screenings with it i know it's
entertaining to audiences i mean i've
been in so many festivals with the movie
and i've watched real audiences not
friendly audiences people who know me
like you know complete strangers watch
and critique the movie so i know it's an
entertaining movie so when somebody says
it's not an entertaining movie then i
say i respectfully disagree but you get
to say it because i because you own the
audience and i don't
but that's okay that's their prerogative
it's their business
when we played that one little game
before which i really liked where you
said
what's your movie and now i need you to
fill a hundred seats from people that
are not friends and families co-workers
whatever
do you ever run out by your students and
do it and do they yeah yeah that's right
that's right in my class oh okay okay
that's like lesson two in my class oh i
love it i like that game i actually
should become a board game well no it's
because it really gets you to think
critically and and it makes the stakes a
little higher to really really dig in
and say okay who would i put into those
seats
and what do they say like what are some
of the ideas that these students have
come well it depends on the movie
you know like uh you know i don't want
to get into too many details because you
know it's a i don't want to
it's not fair to my students whatever
like like one of the groups did pulp
fiction okay you know so um
they went into a lot of detail of who
that movie goal would be now there's
probably tons of research on the
internet that they probably could have
borrowed from i don't know but they
thought about you know
what age group what demographic you know
where
what that type of movie would attract
that type of thing so
you know and
they
gave me reasons of why they thought that
was the people and it doesn't matter
again whether it's right or wrong
because there aren't no writer there
aren't right and wrong answers
um
it's about the reasons why you do the
critical thinking you do so they say you
know they could say that's for 12 year
old girls and as long as they tell me
why they think that and it's rational
then they'll get a good mark now i
totally disagree that movie is obviously
not for 12 year old girls because
there's so much violence and swearing
and all that kind of stuff but they
wouldn't say that obviously but they
might say you know males uh
50 to 70 and i might say well you know
it's probably males you know 30 to 50.
but you know tell me why you think 50 to
70 and they might say because
we think that those males are more
mature and have more time and would like
the violence better or something like
that as long as the reasoning is good
it's about the critical thinking because
it's constantly changing as i said right
so i want to create critical thinkers
who who can be creative and just
be rational now they'll work in teams
ultimately when they're in the working
world and
and it's good to have different input
and and different ideas
you know and as long as you're not crazy
and delusional you know and coming as
long as you it's about thinking about it
that's what that's what learning is
about is about
thinking critically about something and
and trying to understand it best you can
it's not about
right and wrong necessarily in this
this isn't math there's not a right
answer and a wrong answer
this is about how you come to it
was there a waiting period after you
pitched netflix the first time
yeah um
you mean until until i got an answer
i had the six weeks or so something like
that they had to circulate the movie
internally a bit and think about it a
bit
that i can't remember exactly but it
wasn't it wasn't that long like it
wasn't more than that
maybe maybe four weeks
something like that it was relatively
soon god you know you're sitting on pins
and needles the whole time you're so
anxious
but you know they do fairs for you know
they have million things to look at and
they you know they have to get opinions
of few people
when netflix said yes to you what did
that yes mean
it meant that i just became a real
filmmaker
now it meant like
it's surreal at first to be honest with
you it's like holy smokes but first of
all
you gotta understand i am so skeptical
about everything because i've been in
business by myself for so long
that i've seen so many deals fall apart
so the truth is and i hate to say it the
truth is and i do this with everything
so people
if anybody who's ever worked for me
knows what i'm about to say it's like
the deal's not a deal until the money is
the check has been cashed and cleared in
the bank so even though you have a deal
in writing even though it's all signed
sealed delivered you've delivered the
movie when the money comes and it clears
then it's a deal
and everybody says like why can't you
just celebrate they said yes you have a
contract here it is they're taking
delivery i said yeah
but i've seen lots of deals there where
they falls apart at the end the very end
even though it's what are you going to
do you're going to sue netflix you're a
little like lowly filmmaker and you're
going to take them you know and you'll
probably settle or something like that
if the deal were to fall through
but i kind of wait until the very end so
as much as i was thrilled and happy
it wasn't done until it was paid for
do you think that's a good model to go
by do you think too many people are
trusting and get their hopes up and so
that's when you said you'd been through
so much and so much rejection yeah it
seasoned you in a way that
you you're you're more opt to close any
gaps that yeah it's not a good way to be
i mean it's good to be able to really
celebrate and everything like that but
but the word you use is right it's
seasoned that comes with experience i
mean
generally when you've done being in it
enough time that's any business not just
the film business but you know when
you've done enough times and you've seen
sort of what the scenarios are and how
it plays out
i just don't want to set myself up for
disappointment and i
underst you know especially when it's
new territory like it wouldn't happen
now with netflix now i've got enough
experience and i know who they are and
they're big enough company and
everything like that but back then it
was the first deal i didn't know what to
expect and i'd
seen a deal go sour a really good deal
that i had done before a few years
earlier went sour at the 11th hour like
it was a done deal and it went sour and
i was in a position to you know sue but
i
pursuing's not a good route to take
because
it's costly and you don't want to ruin a
relationship you know so so i guess i'm
a little jaded no i'm a lot jaded but
for good reason i'm i am
have a lot of experience i'm super
seasoned and you get jaded when you're
seasoned
but i do still allow myself to celebrate
when the time comes but
i choose when the time is
how many guaranteed ways are there for a
filmmaker to get their film to netflix
guaranteed ways
that's a kind of a loaded question
almost like it's
it's like it's like leading a witness
there's no guarantees
you're talking netflix i mean the only
guarantee is i mean there's two
guarantees one is you're making the
movie for netflix because they hired you
it's a netflix original and they hired
you to make the movie that's guaranteed
because they own the movie and they
hired you
or two is they pre-buy the movie from
you based on an idea or a license which
highly highly highly is unlikely those
are the two guarantees otherwise
you know you do it you hope for the best
i mean but both of those first scenarios
are generally
netflix original movies where it's not
really your movie you're just making it
for them
what are some of the non-guaranteed ways
to get on netflix that just
shot in the dark
well the first non-guaranteed way is
make a movie make it really really good
create a lot of awareness for it
you know not necessarily give it away on
youtube for free but do something that
gets a lot of maybe social media
activity something that you do special
or maybe release or something like that
that's probably the best non-guaranteed
way because it will put you in a league
where you'll be able to get their
attention because now
two things have happened one is you've
made a good movie it's finished so they
don't you're not pitching them on an
idea you're pitching them on a finished
film
and two is you've also gotten an
audience which they want audience their
business is not about content their
business is audience they're in the
business of signing subscribers remember
that the way they subsidize signed
subscribers is to create good content
now they're also in the content business
now so someday
the value of their content library is
going to be worth a ton of money it
probably already is right now
but the major asset is subscribers and
they create good content to get
subscribers so if you can show to them
that you already have like a ton of
interest
and maybe some of those people will
become subscribers if they put their
movie your movie on their service
that's a gigantic plus for them
you know like if you're dealing with say
a niche audience right and they don't
maybe have that niche audience or think
that they could sign another you know 20
30 40 50 000 subscribers based on that
movie
they're gonna be all over that
so that's the best non-guaranteed way to
do it but it's you know you're making a
movie it's super risky and they also
might say no and they may never see the
movie like how do you get it to them
right you gotta have an agent or a
manager or somebody or the best way as i
said last time is to go through an
existing distributor who already has a
relationship with them
but the best way to get that distributor
is to have that audience to have that
awareness to have that notoriety already
it's not just it's not this is where the
narrative is different it's not good
enough anymore to say hey i have a great
movie it's not good enough even to have
laurels from you know low end film
festivals i mean if you have the
audience choice award from toronto or
can yeah you're good but who gets that
one movie you know a year and it's
probably you know so chances are you're
not going to have that what's good
enough is you've done some marketing and
created a lot of awareness and all of a
sudden
the distributor
slash who's going to talk to netflix can
say
look how much interest we already have
we're not only bringing a movie we're
bringing an audience with it
seems like a lot of authors are doing
that as well so it's very similar
they don't get signed sometimes by these
big publishing houses until they've
proven that they have a big social media
following right i could be wrong about
that but but the good news is for here's
the good news for indie filmmakers if
we're going to take one piece of good
news is
the because of the digital world you can
actually do that now you can actually
reach out to the audience yourself now
it's a super crowded marketplace because
they're inundated with all kinds of
stuff but you know
10 20 years ago you could not connect
with the world
with individuals around the world now
you can
um like i say it's just hard to get
through all the clutter but at least the
it exists the technology exists to do it
so if you got a message and you know how
to work it and manage it and you know
maybe create this niche area where you
can get it out there at least
it's available to do it whereas before
you had to do generic television
advertising or or print advertising
whatever and spend a ton of money and
not even know if you're connecting with
your audience
is that something that your
students are concerned with how do they
kind of rise above the noise
because there's so much we're inundated
with every day yeah i don't think young
people are as concerned about that
because they're part of the noise they
are the noise right
um i see it as noise because i'm used to
other stuff but but there they are the
noise right so they're well way more
connected than i am way more up to speed
on all the platforms um you know it's
constantly changing obviously
i'm not hip you know i'll tell you the
funniest thing the the one compliment my
oldest son paid to me so the back-ended
compliment was
dad
the only thing cool about you
is that you actually know that you're
not cool
i took it as a compliment okay no that
was a total compliment you know it took
so much pressure off me like i didn't
want to have to chase around and try to
you know pretend that i knew all these
platforms and that i was on instagram
and doing this and all that kind of
stuff
i i don't want to do tick-tock videos i
just don't want to do that stuff i i
recognize that it is super important and
that there's a gigantic world out there
and it's very big for marketing i
recognize it totally
but at my age and who i am i'm not i'm
not going to do that i'm going to hire
people or can you know i'm going to
circle myself with people who who are
good at it who want to do it who enjoy
it more than i do so i'm not saying it's
not important because it totally is i'm
just saying i know who i am and i don't
want to try to be some cool instagram
you know
person or i don't want to be a youtube
influencer
i guess maybe through these videos i'm a
little bit but yeah i think you all no
no but what i'm saying is like i don't
have to do these silly weekly videos
that you know are going to do crazy
stuff to make me
i don't even want to do weekly webcasts
or podcasts i it's just i'm not
interested
so that's what he meant at least you
know who you are and you're not
interested in that now having said that
the young people
are super interested in all that kind of
stuff and it's great because the tools
and listen there's a lot of people who
might be in my class or you know who are
in that generation who are going to
change the world right they're going to
come up with new technologies are
they're going to work in companies that
apply these technologies and and do
special things that that are going to
you know change the way people think and
and new habits and new ways i mean look
what's gone on in the last year
with the whole black lives matter and
the whole i mean these are social
movements that change the way people
think and the whole world
and so
that's great you know that these are
that's the generation that's gonna
embrace that and take and take charge
and hopefully we'll do you know do good
with it
that's great that you have so many sort
of ears and eyes that are able to
tell you different things whether it's
students or your sons
and and
you can kind of see them in action with
whatever
on whatever platform yeah you know
because some people don't and
you know there's so many things that are
changing and evolving oh this platform's
not not no one's using this now so you
know it's funny for my students so when
we were doing the marketing part and i
was talking about social media i
literally said to them at the beginning
of that lecture i said
what i'm about to tell you is what i
know but i'm pretty darn certain
hopefully that i'm right that you know
way more than i do so i'm just going to
go through the motions and in your
papers i'm going to learn more from you
from in this section then you're going
to learn from me
because i know that you are active on
these platforms and i'm not now we
talked about buying facebook ads and
stuff like that which is you know i
don't do it i hire people to do that so
i understand how it all works and how to
target and do that kind of thing and
they don't didn't know about some of
that stuff
but they're going to be way better at it
than i am and it's way more savvy
because that's who they are
each deal that you've received on
netflix has it improved each time it's
three films yes it has
that might be a combination of a couple
things one is
i got lucky
it could be that i just got lucky that
they were paying more each time
two is maybe the films are better but i
don't think they're necessarily better
in terms of the production quality
um but i think maybe it's because they
see that my films are getting an
audience and they're maybe worth a bit
more
so they being fair really fair because
they control that side you know you can
have a little bit of a discussion but
for the most part they say here's
where you're going to fit in
and if you say no they got 50 other
films waiting in line to fit in so
there's a little bit of room wiggle room
but not a heck of a lot but at least if
they say you're this is what the film is
worth and and they recognize that the
value is there because they have an
audience and they know it because they
had an audience for the previous one so
so it's similar audiences so that's
maybe why they've been fair like that
have you made any pitches to netflix
during the pandemic
yeah
yeah of course i have
i mean you know the pandemic does i mean
i can't shoot anything um but i i did
pitch them on the movie i wanna shoot
and uh
you know they're interested but but i i
told them i'm not shooting during the
pandemic so maybe that's my bad but
i think everybody understands that right
but it was another scenario where it
looks good sounds good we like division
we like the style of movies you make and
everything like that but you're going to
need to make it and make sure you make
it well
it's still good
do i have a tracker with them yeah do i
have relationships yeah
it's still a new adventure every time
though
you know because they're i'm a little
tiny
speck of dust in in their universe
and i know it um you know maybe i
shouldn't belittle myself that much but
um so i don't take for granted i you
know you got to deliver and it's got to
be good and it's got to resonate and by
the way i still plan on doing all that
audience awareness stuff that i talked
about
even more so now now that i'm really
aware of it and real niche and lots and
lots of marketing before it goes to them
if they're going to take it so that i
can bring audience to them i want to be
able to say the major pitches to them is
like yeah here's the story and it's a
good movie and it's going to resonate
but the major pitches look at the
audience that i think i'm going to be
able to bring to you because of all the
marketing i've done
what constitutes niche in the eyes of a
of a platform like netflix or hulu or
disney
um it's it's specific like you know i
tend to make family movies and primarily
sports dramas so this one's also a
sports drama based on a true person you
know true uh
like a true life story
so niche would be
sort of what the sport is
who this the person is that we're
talking about if there's some sort of
like community around that person that
would be interesting
um you know
to use a very very big example i mean
obviously this is way bigger than what
i'm talking about but so netflix
recently released the tiger woods um you
know two-part series and it wasn't it
was some filmmaker made it about tiger
woods and it was really really well done
it's a matter of i can't believe how
well done it was based on the fact that
he didn't he wasn't part of it they
like it wasn't you know an authorized
biopic they did it based on footage they
got anyways i i love golf and so so look
at the niches there i mean first of all
you've got the celebrity of tiger woods
in the sports world
you've got the whole golf world because
pretty well anybody who's a golfer is
going to watch that so there's you know
you deal with the pga the professional
golf association and you know there's
lots of associations you know like i
remember the southern california golf
association everybody heard about it
through that so we all got it very niche
target marketing to the golf world
obviously to the overall sports world
and then you know the general stuff is
to the celebrity world because he's a
major celebrity you know in his own
right even though he's an athlete but
you know he's probably more well known
in the world than any actor is or you
know way up there with them
so but you know they say that's an
extreme example because you're talking
like probably the most well-known
athlete in the world
but the niche is the golf thing right
and so even if it wasn't tiger
if it was some unknown golfer
he still could have gone into the golf
world because generally like i guarantee
i know a lot more golfers than you know
on the pga tour i think so um so if they
had used somebody who wasn't the
notoriety of tiger but you know somebody
who was i was interested in as a golfer
they could target me and that alone
would be and you know and then it's also
demographics you know generally a lot of
people who call for
more so male than female but you know it
goes both ways but you know they they
there's ways to target that
sure and that's a good demographic
because that that's someone that's going
to have disposable income
to spend on things
even if you're not putting it on a
platform where it's just whatever
fifteen dollars a month and that might
be a good place to start getting someone
yeah i would imagine i mean look at
netflix has such a big audience that i
always assume everybody's got netflix
but they don't but i always assume
everybody does
but i you know i would imagine that you
know there's there were a lot of golfers
who maybe don't have a netflix
subscription that maybe did sign up for
a netflix subscription just to watch
that special
and it was well it was really well done
so they probably got their money's worth
now will they stay subscribers i don't
know that's up to netflix to start to
profile them and feed them other golf
stuff or whatever stuff you know netflix
is good at that
right suggested yeah films yeah
what's different about the pitching
process with netflix now versus prior
years 2015 2014
like i said before it's bigger company
so they generally they don't take
pictures that's a different um you know
i've done business with netflix for
three films but i'm not going to call
myself a netflix expert there are people
who do way more business than i do
especially different types of business
like internally you know i haven't done
any netflix originals i've talked to
them about it
there's a different department and
different style and all that kind of
stuff so i just sort of know what i know
as an outsider and again i'm not
i guess i'm much further ahead than any
indie filmmaker who hasn't done any
business with them but
like i feel like i'm not
that qualified to talk about it but i
guess more so than others but
the pitching you know what makes it
different i mean it's just uh
back then i mean they took pitches they
just don't take them they don't have the
time or the interest
unless it's it's done through you know
the right channels which is agents or
distributors so it's you're basically
locked out now
how are your pitches different now
knowing that they're a bigger company
they have less time they have so many
people trying to get into that front
door yeah
my pitches to everybody not just netflix
anybody who i'm dealing with are shorter
and more concise and right to the point
because of lack of time and they hear so
much
so i get right down to it
one it's almost a log line like here's
the movie here's what it's about
and here's the audience and here's how
we're going to go after that audience
and here's what i'm going to bring to
the table as a result here's the
marketing i'm going to do
and it's
like i say i try to keep it to five
minutes
and then the rest is hopefully questions
um but that's all you really need
you can get to i could do it in 20
probably 30 seconds but i spread it out
just a little bit so i'm not talking too
fast
but yeah back then i was pitching as i
said in the last video you know i would
do 20 to 30 minutes for a pitch tell
them about the story tell them about
this the actors how we're going to shoot
and they don't care nobody cares about
that stuff just make a darn good movie
tell us who the audience is and and you
know deliver
so if i was at netflix you've just just
pitched me
um
what are my questions going to be to you
or am i just sending you out the door
thank you very much we'll look it over
no but remember i'm not going to get a
pitch for something that i'm unless it's
a netflix original
and and in that case i'm sort of just
telling them the idea
and that's more about the script because
they're just basically going to buy the
script and maybe hire me to make the
film or maybe just take the script and
make it internally with one of their
crews
so you know potentially i could be hired
on you know maybe to direct or something
and then we would talk it's all artistic
it's not about audience anymore because
they're gonna own the film they'll
control that they'll bring all that to
the table
so the other flip side is pitching a
finish film you've already finished the
film so you don't have to talk about the
story or this or that so back then
i would do that now i don't talk about
any of that because here's the film like
just watch the film i don't have to tell
you what like that's why i say it's
one sentence about the log line you know
but but here's the film you either want
it or you don't want it based on the
movie itself
so they're hearing the log line they're
taking the materials maybe they'll
they're watching it
and then they'll watch the movie for
sure no no unlike distributors they'll
definitely watch the movie no i mean
they don't watch every movie they'll
watch the first 10 minutes and if they
like it then they'll watch the next 10
minutes and hopefully they get through
the whole thing right to make sure that
it's
okay
but the reason that they'd be interested
is because there's an audience attached
to it
because there's like i say
if i if i had 10 seconds to pitch
netflix on and that's all you got right
maybe i should suggest this to netflix
give every indie filmmaker 10 seconds
you know speed pitching right or 20
seconds or something like that i
wouldn't even tell them the name of the
film all i'd say is i have 2 million
viewers on youtube who've already seen
it and want to see it on netflix that's
the pitch
hopefully that's the case
and they'd say oh by the way what's the
name of the film
you sure you got the two million prove
to us you got the two million let's see
it did you
jigget did you do something
that's the pitch
i mean you know the film matters
but the audience matters more
can we reenact the pitch that you did
for your last movie
sure to netflix how did you let's
suppose i'm the person on the other side
of the desk
great to see you have a seat
you know
can you get him some water coffee great
thank you no that didn't even happen
they have a nice station in the lobby go
get yourself a drink a coffee whatever
and no when we get up to the meeting
room let's get right into it all right
so the pitch was very simple it was like
i want to make another the the the
olympics are coming in two years
um i believe that we did well with our
first movie with full out
and i would like to make another
gymnastics movie similar to that because
with the olympics coming we know that
women's gymnastics is a big thing in an
olympic year
and you've already developed that
audience with the first movie would you
be interested in having another one and
i've already got a story and i got an
idea of who we would do it with it would
be very similar to the first one
but a you know completely different
storyline but it would engage the exact
same audience and i think that it would
be the timing would be good to deliver
it then
during that olympic year similar to what
we did with the first one
and what was their response
i like it we like it what tell me more
and the more right there in the meeting
okay yeah the answer was yeah that's a
good idea okay what are you thinking i'm
i'm thinking we should do
this this storyline you know again
a minute
um i've got this gymnast you know
um who who did this
and i think it'd make a really good
story and instead of doing hip-hop
dancing i want to do break dancing in
this one so similar type of thing with
two characters that meet
um but let's go into the break world
because it's really cool these days and
the music is really good and i think
that'll resonate
okay great idea
when when you wanted to shoot it and
blah blah blah i'm going to shoot it
then when would you deliver okay we
would need it by here by this time
and
then the number
then
how much would you be willing to pay
and then we get into that
and that takes
a minute or two
now but they also by the way they're
sitting with an ipad and they're saying
oh let's see what did fallout 1 do
yeah okay the numbers look pretty good
all right let's talk about the next one
they would actually give you that number
oh no they don't tell you they they're
looking at their ipad they're not
telling you they're saying yeah okay
looks okay we're good we're good to go
next
i say can you share the can you turn the
ipad around i want to see the numbers no
we don't do that
you know it would be really good i i put
some of my heart and soul into it can't
you just
you know throw me a bone here tease me
give me one number sorry we don't do
that you know we don't do that and they
don't do that that's their proprietary
information and that's the way it works
but
luckily the numbers were good on that
ipad otherwise the conversation would
have been really short
and so this was less than a 10-minute
meeting
this last one the substance was 10
minutes there might have been five
minutes of pleasantries
how are you doing
you know how's the golf game nice office
whatever you know yeah but yeah yeah it
took about 10 minutes but there was one
other piece of business in that movie
because i was wanting to do a renewal on
the first one too it was coming up for
renewal and so
we were talking about both the renewal
and the next one
i see okay yeah and the numbers were
good so both happened the renewal and
the the new one
so that works in your favor obviously so
you go in there with good numbers and
then you pitch them something else it's
everything if the numbers aren't good
it's over
it's over before it starts
yeah i mean there's nothing to talk
about
i mean getting the first one is the
tough one because you don't have any
numbers the second one if your numbers
are good it's really easy meeting and if
your numbers are bad it's a very tough
meeting you got to explain why your
numbers are going to be better the next
time around if they're even interested
to hear it
but the subject matter is super niche i
know that audience really well i've done
tons of marketing to it they know i'm
connected to it they know that i know
how to get to that audience and create
viewership there
so because i've already done the
marketing and now even more so we're
gonna like you know and i explained what
we're gonna do in addition to this with
the dance world that we didn't do last
time so that's music to their ears and
hopefully it works and hopefully they
get new subscribers as a result of it i
mean i want them to be successful
because if they're successful then
hopefully they greenlight something else
i'm going to do
and that's just supporting their efforts
how are you sharing your ideas for
marketing the film that you're pitching
so with netflix or with everybody i mean
let's see
for this
for this case yeah netflix oh i'm
telling them straight up i'm saying okay
we're going to start with the gymnastics
the usa gymnastics
which is their network of all the gyms
across the united states and the coaches
so we're gonna we're gonna get an
endorsement from them
i had a special olympian in there so
we're going to you know special olympics
we're getting their endorsement meaning
they'll put the message out to all of
their athletes and families of which
they have many
we i'm dealing with
the dance magazine and dance world so
there's all kinds of dance tons of dance
clubs
and studios and so i'm advertising
through them i'm doing both paid
advertising and social media and then
we're doing some a whole bunch of of
web-based stuff with one of our key
dancers so
the main breakdancer in the movie is a
world-renowned breakdancer and so she
did interactive stuff that we had all
planned pre-planned as part of the
promotion
um and so they don't know anything about
the breaking world i didn't know much
about it either i learned about it
obviously but
so as i explained it to them and they
looked up you know who this is and what
these communities are and how to get to
them and everything like that and you
know that's probably a good audience for
them and they probably have a lot of
that audience already but you know it's
interesting for for them to hear about
it so these are things that you know
you're explaining not in a ton of detail
just enough to you know tweak their
interests and make them see that you're
going to do some hard work and really
engage try to engage an audience and
that's for everybody's benefit primarily
for the benefit of my movie because i
want audience on it
by the way this is before they say yes
right so i'm doing this anyways
regardless of whether they say yes i'm
doing because i want to be successful
with my movie so if they don't say yes
you know maybe i take it to apple tv and
pitch them the same thing or to you know
to hulu or something like that which by
the way did so you know
i mean you know because you're waiting
six weeks you're not sitting there with
your thumb up your butt waiting for an
answer you're pitching everybody because
you
you know you hope that
somebody comes through and you hope it's
the one you want but it's kind of like
applying for
for lack of a better example college
you don't apply to one you apply to one
that's a disaster unless you're pretty
darn sure you're going to get in you
apply to 10 or you know and and you hope
that you know you're just hedging your
bets a little bit
so the long line is equally important as
how you'll market to your audience and
who your market who your audience is
it sounds like
neither is more important than the other
you've got to have both the log line is
just for pitching
you know i mean
everybody on their platform doesn't put
just a log line they put a synopsis you
know you go into netflix and you see a
three or four sentence synopsis on every
film
so the log line is just when you're
pitching it's the yellow it's what the
people call the elevator pitch thing you
know you got three floors in an elevator
and you better get it out quickly so you
just get a log line in there that sort
of captures what the movie's about and
then as soon as you capture their
attention then they might ask you more
details and you can go into a little bit
more detail
but i find by the way i find that
filmmakers the big mistake they make in
pitching and they do this all the time
when i'm consulting with them
is they talk way too much about the
story
i mean we all know story elements we get
it we know genres i mean i know
pretty well all of them so
just like tell me the details because i
say to them this is the irony so they're
paying me
for their time you know they might book
an hour right and they're paying for
that and they start going into the story
and i say no no no let me stop here for
a second i don't want you wasting your
time your paid time telling me your
story i get it i get the audience i get
who you're talking about i don't need
the details of the story i'm sure it's
great i'm sure it's unique let's get
into the substance the substantive stuff
which is the marketing and the
distribution all that kind of stuff
because don't take 20 minutes to tell me
your story because they would otherwise
because they're so engaged in their
story
and it's not about the story i mean it's
obviously at the end of the day when you
make the movies about the story but it's
not about the story at that at that
stage
that's why i was wondering is how
important it sounds like then the
synopsis or log line whatever it is
you're going off to pitch them is
equally important as
who's your demographic
who how are you getting to them well
think about it like you're sitting there
you're netflix buyer right i'm saying to
you i'm going after the dance world in
the gymnastics world
okay as long as i have a decent story
where there's characters and character
arcs and development everything like
that i mean the question they need to
ask is how many dance routines am i
going to have how many gymnastics
routines am i going to have oh yeah
what's the main character and what's
their relationship but you know how many
big production scenes are going to like
kids want to see the gymnastics and the
dance that's what they really want to
see and as long as it's not a disaster
you know the rest of it you know it's
got to have a story that weaves through
and a compelling storyline and like i
say character x and everything like that
but
but if you have all that
and you don't have good production like
you don't have any dance sequences or or
gymnastics competitions or something
like that it's not going to be a good
movie for that audience
so that's really what
if you understand who your audience is
and i understand my audience because you
know i make movies for them then i'm
saying to netflix this is what my
audience wants to see and they
understand that because they have shared
audience and they understand what
audiences like to see fame tv show fame
yeah for sure all of the dance routines
interwoven they had they had trouble
cheering they had cheer on there that
sure was a series that they did about
cheerleading so they understand that
market really well
um but now that's in the department that
acquires that's the licensing side so
that's who i'm pitching to is they're
going to acquire the movie right if
you're pitching to netflix originals
where you're talking story this pitch
might be totally different it might be
way more about story character arc plot
points all this kind of stuff i mean
they're going to get more into the
artistic side of it because
they're going to be making the movie
with you so they want to see some of the
artistic vision but this is you're
making a movie and you're going to tell
them why it's marketable and you're
hopefully going to make a good movie
that they're going to buy they're not
involved at all artistically
so it's sort of a different style
altogether not sort of it is it is
you're not talking creatives with them
you're talking about audience that
you're going to resonate with when you
deliver this finished film the film's
done they have no say in it because it's
you can't change it it's over
whereas in the other side the netflix
original it's nothing's happened yet
they can change everything and you would
have a broader audience for this because
i'm thinking of like the tv show dance
moms i believe i've never actually
watched it i've just seen trailers but
you have not only the the
kids in the in the thing that are the
dancing the dancers sorry but um you
also have the the mom so you have a much
wider you have parents and you have
their kids oh yeah and i just told you
two components i went you know break
dancing and gymnastics of course there's
there's lots of ancillary stuff and
everything yeah now i have a whole
marketing plan i just didn't want to
spend too much time on this interview
talking about it but we could go into a
lot more detail
you know about like all the components
of what we did i mean i did a whole
bunch of promotions too like for example
i'll just give you one
um you know we shot that particular
movie we shot in oklahoma city
at the university of oklahoma with the
oklahoma sooners it's about one of their
gymnasts and it's shot on location there
so i did a huge promotion in oklahoma
city with pizza hut
you know and i created a lot of
awareness by doing a pizza top box
topper that goes out to you know i don't
know 50 000 pizzas they sell in whatever
period it was um so that the local
audience because you know the girl's
wearing a oklahoma sooners outfit that's
the key art so everybody in oklahoma
city knows who the sooners are you might
not know but everybody there does from
seeing your movie yeah okay so
so that's local stuff yeah we also did
lots of television you know um publicity
spots there we got a lot of ads and not
ads but we got a lot of
spots on local editorial public they
were all interested that a movie was
being shot on location about a true
story about one of their gymnasts so we
got lots and lots of that which i used
in that market more so i'm not going to
use that nationally because it doesn't
resonate but locally it resonates really
well
so you know but the netflix of the world
understand all that stuff because their
business is engaging audiences so they
get something you know like some kansas
city reporter doing a story of you know
brennan dowell which is what happened
is great in kansas city and that's good
you know and what does that mean to
netflix it's one tiny component of their
entire
base but it's better than nothing and
maybe they can you know sign up ten you
know a thousand more subscribers there
in that marketplace based on that maybe
this is micromanaging running a business
so you know and building your audience
no those are great details and i love
that and i love that you would think of
pizza hut maybe that's something that
but families are going to be ordering
pizza and who's going to want to see
the pizza hut thing first of all there's
i should have brought it there's a whole
flyer that we printed with a with a
you know a discount on watching the
movie you get a so the reason pizza hut
was in was so the the win-win was
they stuck this flyer it was like a
postcard size thing of the graphic and
i'm saying new movie available you know
on the following platforms and it's like
you know six
transactional platforms um and then the
flip side is special promotion from
pizza hut 50 off in this market with
this pizza and here's the code and you
stick it in and you get it for 30 days
you can watch the movie for half price
with the purchase of this pizza so it's
a win-win but hold on that was just one
i mean that's one promotion i do tons of
those and and pizza hut was just one of
the there's 10 pizza chains so i pitched
like five of them not just pizza hut i
wanted pizza hut but if pizza had said
no you know maybe it was dominoes you
know i mean you're pitching everybody
but like i say i spend way more time
marketing than i do on making movies way
more time that's the kind of stuff
you're talking about and to kind of go
back to what i was talking about before
filmmakers first of all don't even know
about this kind of stuff secondly what
filmmaker wants to do that film like
talking to 10 pizza joints to figure out
a local pizza promotion you don't want
to do that you want to make movies
studios have all this built in they just
take for granted all that kind of stuff
independent filmmakers don't even know
about this stuff this is stuff that's
totally foreign that they would never
get around to they don't have enough
time to get around to it let alone to do
it
even if they knew about it like i'm
telling you like to me this is like a
no-brainer i'm talking about it it's
like that's nothing compared i can tell
you some way more niche stuff than that
like that is a pretty big promotion i
mean there's stuff that's even smaller
um and you're saying wow that's
interesting and i'm thinking that's not
that interesting i mean that's kind of
what you do
how are you getting a mom and daughter
in chicago to care about
a gymnast from oklahoma
because hopefully the daughter's taking
gymnastics or dance
and hopefully she's connected to a
gymnastics or a dance club where her
coach says hey this new movie came out
it's really nice family fair i think you
and your family would enjoy it
and potentially a little bit of social
media where we're targeting maybe
facebook ads that target to that you
know depends how old the daughter is
maybe she's 12 that's our core audience
for that kind of movie
and you know maybe they
facebook has all these analytics and
everything so you know that's part of it
um but yeah we're we're reaching out a
different
the more direct stuff is through the
clubs
and we send we send the clubs every club
got sent a postcard kind of similar to
what i was talking about every club to
the coach
when we did the first one if it wasn't
the pandemic because the clubs were
closed and the first one we sent a
poster to every club and asked them to
hang the poster
you know a sign poster was a nice really
nice poster so that was a nice sort of
thing to put in their lobby
you know um so and that creates
awareness and then of course we have a
website which they go to and get details
and that type of thing and that's
generic marketing i mean it's specific
to that audience but this is what i'm
talking about like
there's so much involved in marketing i
mean when you do marketing for a living
that's not that special what i just said
and it's special but not that special
but when you do filmmaking
all of a sudden marketing is like holy
smokes i didn't even know about this
stuff like this is this is really good
like i i didn't even know you could do
that kind of stuff yeah there's a
creativity in what you're telling me
because there's different things you can
plug in here and it's a challenge it
doesn't sound that easy there's
creativity in knowing what to do and
then there's execution and actually
doing it which is a lot of work if that
stuff doesn't come overnight you got to
work it and you got to negotiate it and
contract it and deliver and print and do
all this kind of stuff but you know when
it works it you can get really good
results
how has the pandemic changed the film
business
great question very timely
um the major
change is obviously the theatrical
business you know theater's closing so
that's had a huge impact on how movies
are viewed now especially you know the
big blockbuster tentpole releases
uh so that's a big one but
that also caused a huge change in in the
whole vod world like the streaming world
so all these studios that were probably
thinking about you know becoming uh
subscription video on demand services
had it in the
works
likely accelerated their plans and now
all of a sudden you've got you know
eight or ten major
streaming services when before you had
netflix really was it and then you know
an amazon prime and then of course
disney plus was starting up but disney
plus really jumped in quickly
and then everybody followed so i think
that the studios realized they needed
another you know avenue to
to exhibit their movies because they
couldn't depend on the theaters
obviously and
you know that accelerated that so much
and i'm not sure if it's good or bad i
think for indie films it's actually not
good which i'll talk about later um but
probably for overall viewership for for
consumers now there's such a vast choice
of quality programming
that's available at really affordable
prices so i guess that's good now me
personally i love going to the movies
like i like a night out at the movie
theater i love watching you know a big
movie on in a big format on a huge
screen with a great sound system you
know in a very confined you know like
dark room like that
so i for one will be back at the movies
the minute they start up i mean because
i it's a night out for my wife and i i
love watching a movie that way
hopefully a lot of people are thinking
like me and can't wait to get back to
the movies but
you know a lot of people went out and
bought really big you know flat screen
tvs and good sound systems and you know
and i i did too and i enjoy that it's
been a great way to watch you know
content in the comfort of your own home
uh but i i believe that the theatrical
business will be back and it will be
healthy and robust and just because
human beings
need to go out and need to socialize and
that's a night out
do you think
things will be totally the same as they
were let's say 2019 right right toward
december of 2019
once things start to open up
i know we're on the eve of it as of this
interview but do you think things will
be returned to that exact level or there
will be changes yeah i mean it's all
driven obviously by the the major
studios because they have the big
programming that people want to see so
i don't know just because there's going
to be a decision made corporately in in
each of their boardrooms and they're
going to say hey let's do the math on
this if we open you know theatrically
for six to eight weeks pre vod
what will the numbers look like if we go
day and date what will the numbers look
like i mean it's all about numbers right
i mean they're in business to make money
and they got to decide what is the best
way to you know to cater to their
audience so that they can make the
revenue they want to make
so i really don't know um i know the
theaters i don't know for sure but what
i've read is the theaters obviously are
going to want an exclusive window you
know pre the vod release
but
maybe the studios have learned something
new that may carry on and frankly i mean
as a consumer that's not going to matter
to me i don't really care whether
there's a day-and-date vod release with
the theatrical release i'll still go to
the movie theater to see the movie
because i want to see it that way and i
will pay my 15 and buy my popcorn
everything because i want to go out i
mean i want to i want to watch those big
movies that way
so even if they're offered at the same
time you know on vod i'm still not going
i'd rather consume it that way now if
they're not and that's a way to get
subscribers by offering them day and
date that's a corporate decision and you
know i'll understand
but i don't know movie theaters so if i
did i wouldn't understand
how has the pandemic changed your
company and you as a filmmaker that's a
great question
well my company did not make a movie in
2020 we were supposed to i have a great
other new sports drama that i was hoping
to shoot and
i've already kind of almost set up
pre-distribution for it so i was really
excited about it
and
but the pandemic slowed that down
because the protocols for shooting were
very very restrictive and plus
personally i don't really want to do
that i mean i don't i didn't want to put
my own health at risk i didn't want to
put the crew or the cast or anybody at
risk so i didn't feel it was worth it to
to have to shoot during the pandemic and
it's still in you know it's still sort
of waiting
um i'm hoping maybe we could shoot this
fall but uh we have to see how that all
plays out but um i'm respectful of the
fact that hey it's a pandemic crazy
thing crazy year crazy almost year and a
half now
um by the time this is over um but it
happens
and
you know
we'll get through it and we'll see what
looks like on the other end
so i'm anxious to to shoot a game but i
didn't want to shoot during the pandemic
which meant i had like you know a year
more little more than a year to do other
stuff
so that actually
was interesting and you know at first i
was kind of disappointed but then i said
let's make you know lemons into lemonade
here
so i did two things one is i stepped up
my consulting practice quite a bit so i
do a lot more consulting with indie
filmmakers
and
you know i'm enjoying that because
everybody is kind of struggling and
going through the same thing and it's
nice to chat with people
and give them advice and i think i've
connected with a lot of filmmakers and i
feel like they've learned a lot and i've
hopefully helped them through stuff and
i'm sure some of them will be watching
this interview and hopefully make nice
comments
but also i started teaching too
so i live in san diego i teach at san
diego state university and i teach in
the film production department but i
teach the business aspects of indie
filmmaking so it's primarily
distribution and finance
which are the boring parts of the film
business you know the students want to
learn about camera and lighting acting
directing editing all that kind of stuff
you know film making right production
so
they have to take my course to graduate
if you're if you're a film major and
they learn about
finance and distribution primarily a
little bit about budgeting and and
scheduling
um and so it's been interesting because
at first the students are you know
a little leery of it you know because
they don't realize what that entails but
i've
really gotten great feedback on that
from all the students who are taking my
course and they're primarily upper level
students
um
because they didn't really understand
distribution at all i mean they've heard
the word but they had no clue what it is
i talk a lot about marketing and you
know how to kind of make sure that
you've got
your plans in place before you start
shooting so that maybe you'll do things
differently during your shoot if you
need to
um and you know the whole financing
piece everybody's really curious about
how that is all gets put together
there's legal terms technical terms lots
of business terms which yeah
people who are artists and filmmakers
don't really love that but totally
appreciate it once they understand how
it all fits together to become you know
the film business
and so in my course i call it the
business of film
um the students call it the film
business i always say you should put the
business part first not the film part
but you know they're both equal i mean
you need to have the art obviously the
artistic side but they're taking
you know a dozen courses on that side
and one course in business and you know
maybe that will expand into more i
believe in order to be a successful
filmmaker as i've said many times in
your interviews and to other people
it's really helpful to know what really
goes on on the business side primarily
the distribution side
you don't have to do it all and i tell
people you don't have to become an
expert in it but it's good to understand
it to at least be aware
what goes on what other people do so
that you you know you can be part of the
conversation and the narrative and and
just be
a little bit more up to speed so that
when you do cross those bridges at least
you know what the bridge is
and what do you start out with once you
get through all of sort of the the
housekeeping of the of the course and
and the timeline and what materials they
need what do you start with so it's
interesting um so i teach in my course
which is the business aspects of
filmmaking i teach three units i teach
distribution production and finance
and i actually teach them in that order
so inevitably the first question i get
asked is why are you teaching
distribution before you teach production
like shouldn't you be teaching you know
all the legals and business aspects of
making a movie which is production
before you teach selling a movie or how
about you shouldn't you teach financing
a movie before you teach selling or
making a movie but i chose those
that that order on purpose because i
said
in order to be a successful filmmaker
because i you know i teach about sort of
commercially viable filmmaking um
obviously you have to be a good artist
you have to make a good film you can't
sell a bad film so i take for granted i
say i assume you're going to make a good
film that's what the other teachers are
teaching at you how to make a great film
so i'll check that box
but before you make that great film you
really need to understand
you know three major things who your
audience is who you're making it for you
know how you're going to create
awareness with that audience and will
your audience pay to consume it if you
want to make money with your movies
and that's all distribution
so it's really important to understand
those components
before you make your film because one is
you might make a different film two is
you might not make the film you're
making i mean
if you really want to look at the
business component so that like at the
end you don't struggle and say oh if i
only would have known or if i had a
thought of that first
that's why i teach distribution first
because distribution really is
enlightening to understand sort of the
film that you're crafting so that you
make the right film so you could sell it
afterwards and and even while you're
making it you have to understand
distribution so that maybe you have
you're making components that help you
market the film or maybe even doing
social media from set or that type of
thing you're marketing marketing
marketing preparing to sell your film
before you make it
have you been surprised by any of the
questions or actually
just pleasantly sort of enlightened by
how
advanced some of these individuals are
when it comes to distribution yeah well
no i mean all i'm going to say
99 i'd say probably 100 of students who
go to film school go to learn production
i mean that's what film school is
teaching you how to make a movie
i think
our school san diego state university
you know
recognized that it's really important to
teach distribution of finance because
those are such important components of
being a successful career filmmaker
but for the most part students don't
expect to learn about those kind of
things because those are sort of the
business things and film schools about
the artistic things so at first
i'm not surprised they're surprised the
students are surprised when they take
the course they have to take my course
to graduate if you're a film major so
it's a prereq you know there's two
prerequisites and you know it's a
mandatory course
so you know i'm the course they don't
want to take because it's all the boring
stuff it's legal business stuff that
type of thing but once they do take it
and they start understanding about you
know how distribution works and what the
different platforms are and how they buy
and sell and and how movies you know get
financed and this kind of thing
they're totally intrigued by it
um they're probably a little overwhelmed
by it as well because there's so much
that they haven't really thought about
you know financing a movie is in my
estimation far more complicated than
making the movie or editing it
um like i say everything's important i'm
not belittling any everything anything
but
to understand you know how the whole
system works from start to finish as a
business
is fascinating for them and and they're
learning a lot
they're learning things that they had no
idea they were going to learn about so
i'm really happy with how much they're
being exposed to and learning but
they're also there's lots and lots of
questions because once you learn a
little bit you want to kind of learn
more and there's just not enough time to
answer it all as a matter of fact i've
had to cut my materials in half twice
because there's just so much to teach
and and
i take for granted because i know it all
you know that they can i can go quicker
but but i have to go a little slower
because you know i just throw around
terms you know like like vod a v o d t v
o d s v o d like you know no big deal
right like that's if you're in the movie
business you know about that
you don't know about that
if you're a film student you don't know
what those platforms are you've heard of
netflix you know you've heard of disney
plus you've heard of some of these
things but
you don't necessarily know what all
these things are so i have to really
take time to explain all that kind of
stuff and it's important because now
they have a very good handle on
potentially where the movies they're
going to make are going to go and of
course it's going to change you know
probably changes all the time but for
now